hello and thank you for tuning in to our
u.s election q a
i'm sarah collinson video journalist at
the economist and i'm joined by zany
minton bedos our editor-in-chief
and john prudeau our u.s editor hi zany
hi john hi sarah
hi john in a prolonged deeply divisive
and nail-biting contest joe biden has
won the presidency
in his first address to the nation he
promised to seek not to divide
but to unify avios have submitted
hundreds of questions
the first comes from sakif al-isan khan
who asks
how challenging will it be for biden to
reunite america
zany what do you think well it will be
challenging
for joe biden to reunite america because
this election has shown that america is
still an incredibly divided country
and those people who were expecting a
complete repudiation of trump and
trumpism didn't quite get that
in the sense that you know president
trump won the second largest number of
votes in american history that anyone
had voted and so
he he did quite well but nonetheless in
the end the result has been clearly
decisive
joe biden has very clearly won and joe
biden i think is
the right kind of person to bring the
country together he's a decent man
he is a man who's naturally bipartisan
you know 47 years in the senate he works
with the other side he wants to do that
and already in the first you know days
hours of him being president-elect you
have seen that you have heard from him
that he wants to unite the country so i
think if anyone can do it he can do it
now
and donald trump is already contesting
the results many of the questions from
our viewers relate to what might happen
in the courts
is joe biden's path to the white house
assured
john what do you think there are a
couple of reasons why
know going anywhere number one the
margin of joe biden's victories
in the key states seems to be large
enough that it'll be
immune from recounts and you know
marginal changes that
court cases might bring and number two
because most of the president's
legal arguments just don't really seem
to go anywhere they seem to be
dead ends i mean there's lots of talk
about how the supreme court might
influence the results of this election
i don't see many of these cases getting
to the supreme court i see most of them
just being tossed out
on arrival kayla p wanted to know about
the next steps for these legal
challenges
are any of them gaining any real
traction danny's shaking her head
rightly so i mean there's this one about
late arriving ballots in pennsylvania
that might go somewhere but if it is
you know if that challenge is successful
it'll affect a really
small number of ballots and joe biden's
won by
a long way in pennsylvania so it's for
the birds really i think that's right
john i think one of the striking things
in the last sort of you know
48 hours is how quickly it has become
clear
actually to many republicans to the
presenters on fox news
that the claims being made by the
president are there's just
no evidence for them there will be
people saying uh you know
there was foul play and they will be
said but it will be a fringe thing
activity and i'm
you know i was really worried i don't
know about you john but before the
election and we had a cover on it in
early september about how
this could get really ugly and it was
called america's ugly election now cover
and i'm now
you know relatively sanguine i think
it's very clear that you know joe
biden's pastor white house is there
and you know the overwhelming majority
of the country republicans included are
accepting this result
i am relatively sorry too zany one thing
we said in that cover leader
was that it the margin of victory
mattered a lot
i think biden's margin of victory
although it feels
tight because it took such a long time
for the results to come in
actually it looks like he's likely to
end up with about 306 electoral college
votes and to win the popular vote by 4
million
that's quite a big margin i think had it
been much
tighter you know had he won you know
pennsylvania
arizona nevada by a couple of hundred
votes at that point i think the
president's claims of fraud
um would have been more damaging than
than they have been
one thing that i think it's worth us
remembering that in some ways
we should have expected this we knew
that huge numbers of democrats
were voting by mail were voting remotely
and that those votes were likely to be
counted later and so i'm sort of
you know i i don't know about you but i
was certainly on overnight on tuesday on
wednesday morning thinking oh my
goodness what on earth is going on here
but actually you know now with the
distance of a few days and a bit of
sleep
we knew that in the most contested
states the people voting on the day were
more likely to be republicans and
therefore this kind of late
improvement in joe biden school was was
absolutely what we should have expected
that's completely right i mean zany we
talked about the blue shift
months before this election night and i
i've written articles about that i knew
in my analytical brain
that that was going to happen and yet
when those results were coming in it's
very hard not to over extrapolate from
50 60 percent of the vote and think oh
you know our model was wrong the polls
are wrong
we got our analysis wrong what did we
miss and in fact we should have just
remembered what we'd written a couple of
months ago let's look at that in a bit
more detail because we've had a lot of
questions coming in
about flawed polls early on when the
results were coming in and we were
looking at
in-person voting and comparing that to
polls it seemed as if there
had been a great polling misfire you
know even worse than 2016.
zany were the polls as far out as we
first thought
well in some ways yes i mean you know
the proposed for example had gave a huge
lead to joe biden in wisconsin and
actually he sort of squeaked to victory
there
and the polls did you know they really
didn't um
show any of what happened in florida
where there was you know this
extraordinary
increase in support for president trump
amongst cuban americans
more broadly the share of the hispanic
vote that he got and indeed
you know from from some african-american
men south texas was a big surprise so
yes you know the polls
did get quite a lot wrong but in the end
they weren't nearly as
wrong as people thought on wednesday
morning overnight on tuesday and i think
the end
result and john you you know the details
of our model which of course is based
um on polls but also on a sort of
underlying
political fundamentals our model didn't
actually perform all that badly in the
end
i agree with all of that and our model
did perform well but that's partly
because it accounted for the possibility
of a large polling error and i think
this was a large polling error
particularly
again in the midwest where we saw the
big polling era
in 2016 and as zany said also
joe biden's lead in polls in florida was
quite small but nevertheless most polls
did show him up and he lost the stake
quite handily what bothers me about the
polls at the moment
and in 2016 is that all the polling
error zanny
and sarah's goes in one direction right
there were no polls that said
joe biden um is down in this state and
then he went on to
to win it so there is a huge problem
with polling in america
and why do you think that might be the
case frank r wanted to know
why trump supporters are so hard to poll
there are various theories about why
this might be one is that
there are shy trump voters who kind of
tell pollsters that they're going to
vote for joe biden but actually vote for
donald trump
from what i can work out i don't think
that's it i think it's more a question
of
people who want to vote for donald trump
just not responding to
polls when pollsters call the
response rate is really low anyway in
2016
only one in 200 phone calls made by a
pollster ended up in a
in an interview which could then go into
the polling sample joe biden got the
most
votes of any presidential candidate in
american history
and donald trump the second most trump's
strategy has always been to play to his
base
but in this election he managed to
broaden it how did he do this
democrats have long argued that high
turnout would benefit democrats the more
people who turned out that would be very
very good for the democrats
actually i think what we've learned is
that high turnout benefits both sides
for me one of the really interesting
lessons of this
this campaign is that the republican
strategy of sort of
white identity politics that's very
closely associated with
with trump you know it may not
necessarily be
the right strategy forward and by by
contrast you know the democrat view that
they will inevitably do well because as
the country is getting more
racially diverse so that necessarily
favors the democrats it's it's not clear
to me that that has to be the case and
that there is therefore an opening there
for a new kind of republicanism that
isn't
trumpism um but that appeals to a
broader more diverse country
i really hope that's true on on the
turnout point
i think it brings us back to where we
began i mean on the one hand as a small
d democrat
it's great to see turn out as high as it
is on the other hand i do think that
high turnout is a function of extreme
partisanship
and the way in which this election felt
like a sort of existential threat
to the future of the country on both
sides and that's why you had so many
um trump voters that's why you had so
many bike voters out so
what would be great for america is you
could if you could keep this high
turnout
without that sense of you know doom
every four years
yeah that's that is absolutely true so
if i'm i've just told you what i feel if
i'm optimistic if i'm feeling
pessimistic then i look at the fact that
both sides were driven
really more by fear and loathing of the
other than anything else
that's what what pushed people out to
vote the senate looks very likely to
remain
in republican control rudy garcia asks
do you think congress will pass any of
biden's proposed legislation
and what would the impact of that be so
assuming it does stay
narrowly in republican hands there is a
view out there that nothing will happen
because you know mitch mcconnell will
you know
block anything that joe biden tries to
do and there'll be the sort of scorched
earth tactics that were used against
president obama
it's possible but i also think there is
some chance
of some cooperation on some aspects
whether it's the stimulus
whether it's infrastructure spending
whether it's even some areas of
climate change policy there'll be much
less than
progressive democrats would like it'll
be much less of an
ambitious transformation but i think
there is a chance for some progress
even with divided government i don't
know about you john are you are you
uh maybe you're a bit more pessimistic
about that than i am i'm a bit more
pessimistic on that than yours i mean
just because
i remember the time you and i were both
based in washington during the obama
presidency
when republicans had a majority in the
senate and it was just a recipe for
gridlock
but maybe i mean i mean you know a
couple of days after the election
there's a feeling of kind of renewal and
optimism i think we've got to start
there
and and hope that they can do it um but
yeah let's see let's see and i think a
lot of it depends
in on where the republican party is
heading
and what the republican party thinks is
its route to victory in 2022 in the
midterms or 2024.
if it thinks it's doubling down on a
kind of you know
new version of trumpism or indeed
trumpism itself then i suspect we're
unlikely to see anything
but if there is a sense that it is
trying to come up with some
somewhat different uh appeal to to a
broader group of people then i think
having
some sense of having worked in a limited
way across the aisle wouldn't
necessarily be a
be a bad calculus for them to make
that's my hope but i'm i am
i'm in determinedly optimistic mood
right now if there is this
gridlock sorry to pull away from your
optimism zany
um one viewer asks whether biden will
have to
govern by executive order to get through
his policy goals
what do you think biden would very much
like to do as much as possible
uh legislatively he's an
institutionalist he's been in the senate
he'd really like to achieve things
through the senate not least because
they're more durable if they're through
the senate but i
think that he won't he won't hold back
from doing things by executive order
if that's the only way to get things
done and certainly there will be quite a
lot of undoing
of president trump's executive orders
and that can be done quickly and then
i'm sure there will be
a lot of very important uh undoing
whether it's in the regulatory area
whether it's on immigration whether
there are sort of some
some totemic trump uh you know actions
which he which president biden would
undo
very very fast i think but beyond that i
think in in sort of really substantive
areas
um whether it's the stimulus whether
it's infrastructure whether it's even
healthcare although i'm even i am not
sure how much can be achieved there
um he would really love to be able to do
something legislatively because that's
the way you actually get durable change
if it's done legislatively we're about
to move on to the international view of
all of this but
just before we do trump has another 73
days as president doug g asks what will
you use this time to do
that is a very very good question and
one could easily
you know get extremely alarmed because
the president of the united states
you know has enormous power i'm actually
not too alarmed i suspect it is going to
be uh
a sort of slightly lonely reality tv
show of a president
fuming brooding furious um
appealing to his base sort of you know
angry about the
the the results saying that it was all
you know unfair and fake
but i wonder whether at some point you
know president trump is is a very savvy
person and he
will be thinking about what is his next
act and is his next bank to run in 2024
and i wouldn't be too surprised if he
sort of announces that is his next act
to become a you know return to being a
major media star
and and as he sort of works at what it
will be don't ever underestimate his
ability
to kind of promote himself market
himself and he'll he'll switch to
whatever he thinks is
you know the most beneficial way to
ensure that he stays the center of
attention for a very long time
there are various things the president
could do through executive order or
executive action particularly in the
area of immigration
also perhaps in foreign policy so we'll
be watching closely over the next few
months to
see if any of that happens but i think
generally the view that he could do all
sorts of awful things on the way out but
you know technically true is probably
overstated there's a limit to what the
president can do
just by fiat thankfully the outside
world has
of course been watching this with baited
breath adam b
asks trump did far better than expected
what signal does this center
other populist movements around the
world well i think that's a very
interesting question
because he did do better than expected
but he didn't win
and in the end you know if you're if you
want to be a successful populist
you've got to win and so i'm i'm not so
sure that this is given
huge sucker i think it has broadly
reinforced the notion
that anti-immigration sort of
populist strongman-ishi kind of tactics
have a large amount of appeal but in the
us at least they didn't have quite
enough appeal to keep him in the white
house
i was based in brazil for three years
for the economist and so on election
night
i was texting with a brazilian friend
who was watching the results coming in
and assumed that my brazilian friend
assumed there was a kind of one-to-one
correlation between how well trump did
and how well bolsonaro
would do in brazil's next election which
just was a reminder for me how many
people around the world
look at american politics and read into
it something about
politics in in their own country i i'd
agree with zany i mean
trump lost and so you know that cast
some doubt on the future of the kind of
nationalist
you know illiberal populism that's been
sweeping the world over the past few
years
but it was not a it was a
defeat but not a repudiation i think so
i think there's enough in there
for those sorts of figures like you know
bolsonaro duterte
and marine le pen to some extent to look
and say well actually you know there's a
lot of people who
who want this stuff and donald trump's
defeat
i think doesn't change that and how
might a biden presidency change the
relationship between
america and china that question's from
elmer deng
i think that's a really really important
question possibly the single biggest
foreign policy question
um and i my answer would be that i think
the rhetoric will change
there'll be more talk of human rights
there'll be more of a sort of
calm approach from the u.s rather than
sort of
overnight sanctions that no one was
expecting but broadly
and this is really important broadly the
position of the u.s will not change
i don't expect any sudden ending of the
tariff war and diminution of tariffs
i don't expect any kind of softer
approach to china
for the simple reason that there is now
a bipartisan consensus
in the us that china is a
strategic competitor that doesn't play
by the rules that is increasingly
aggressive
that needs to be checked and i think
that's felt on both sides of the aisle
one area that i think president trump
history will say that he deserved credit
is that he kind of shook the world to
realizing that that there really it
hadn't been realized so much before
and he really kind of got that on the
agenda and he shook the perception of
china
now what's needed is a you know calmer
more strategic way of thinking about how
do you actually then work with this
second biggest economy
this rising power of the 21st century
which is has a completely different
non-democratic system it's an
authoritarian country that's
increasingly assertive
how do you deal with it and i think that
the hopeful
view is that the foreign policy
establishment types who will be
part of the biden administration will
will kind of take the world as it is now
shaken up by donald trump and apply some
more strategy to it and ideally
work with other allies work with the
europeans work with other allies in asia
to have a kind of united
front um with which to sort of deal with
china
i was talking to david rennie who's the
economist beijing bureau chief about
this the holiday and he
he was somebody who was in washington
with with danny and with me when we were
based there
and he said something interesting which
was that
the experience of trump in beijing and
for the chinese communist party
basically convinced all the officials
there that whatever
american rhetoric might be under biden
basically
america is in the business now of
stopping china's rise trying to prevent
it by any means kind of
fair or foul and i think that's
interesting because you know four years
of donald trump and then donald trump
getting the second highest
vote total in american history i think
is a reminder to
countries abroad that you know he may
have lost but this strain in america is
not going away
and so you know any future deals that
might be made by
biden administration are pretty
contingent really because
the more isolationist streak in american
foreign policy is never
that far away from from winning and i
think that will affect
american foreign policy going forward as
well that's really interesting
and leads very nicely onto the last
question we'll take from our viewers
paramount a wants to know will the
republican party continue with trump's
ideology and methods
into the future so essentially what
happens to trumpism after trump
it's a question our lexington column
grapples with which you can read by
clicking on the link above
danny what do you think so i think
that's that's you know one of the single
biggest questions hanging over american
politics
and um i i would answer it the following
way i think there are sort of
two elements to trumpism if you will
there is the element that has to do with
the personality
of donald trump himself the
unpredictability the divisive rhetoric
the kind of you know contempt for
institutions the
the sort of nasty approach if you will
to to the conduct of government
and then there is the the policy element
which is kind of
anti-immigration protectionist
uh very much sort of you know america
first-ish
and i suspect that the republican party
is
actually going to stick with a lot of
those strategic elements i think the
republican party
you know the party of reagan reaganism
was all about deregulation and tax cuts
and the shining city on the hill and you
know a very sort of
um strong and expansive foreign policy
the current
republican party is focused you know
it's a it's a party of
of the kind of white working class if
you will it's a party of america
firstism it's a protectionist party
it's a party that's deeply skeptical of
immigration and i think that's going to
stay
i i don't know about you john but i
think that we may have someone whether
it's
you know senator tom cotton whether it's
you know senator marco rubio there are
there are many people who
have broadly the same views as donald
trump but are a sort of
you know cleaned up version of it uh and
will
so you you'll have the kind of bits of
trumpism without trump
i agree 100 with that it's going to be
one of the big questions
that we're covering over the next few
months and few years really i mean right
until dara i mentioned it the next
presidential
primary my assumption like you zany is
that the republican party is the party
of the white working class
for the next few cycles at least and the
republican party has
struggled for a while to come up with a
successor to the reagan formula the
deregulation and tax cuts
which was a highly successful formula
but at a time when
personal tax rates were really high in
america and the economy was more heavily
regulated and sort of once you've done
reaganism once you know so what's the
encore and
trumpism um zami described it is sort of
the republican party's
you know best attempt at a sequel i
think to reaganism
and i don't see them ditching it quickly
that said you know just to echo what
zany says
it's unclear how trumpism without trump
works
i don't know what the trump movement
would look like without him
at the head of it we also don't quite
know how he's going
to behave over the next you know two
three four years you know will he keep
teasing the republican party
with the threat of running again in the
primary in 2024
and in which case that will make it
quite hard for the party to
to to move on from him in any meaningful
way one thing i'm really fairly sure
about is that donald trump is not going
to kind of
quietly go off to a golf course and and
sort of fade from the headlines he's
you know he he has his entire career he
craves more than anything being the
center of attention and he's not going
to suddenly stop wanting to do that
and therefore what better way to ensure
that you are continually the center of
attention than to
at least tease the idea that you will
run again in 2024 or if not you one of
your children
and and the sort of trump brand needs
that expectation because otherwise you
know
the whole kind of the trump brand loses
its luster for many many
you know in it for many parts of america
you know it'll become irrelevant and
irrelevance is something
i think that is worrying for donald
trump more than almost anything else
he absolutely will do anything not to be
irrelevant and looking ahead what's the
economist going to be focusing on
in the coming days well i hope john's
going to get some time off he's been
working unbelievably hard john and his
colleagues have done a fantastic job
laying out how we got here and
and i can say that john's too modest to
to do so i think he's done he and his
colleagues have done a really fantastic
job at doing that and now the next step
is to help
our readers and viewers understand where
america is going to go next and i
suspect that means more focus on
you know what will abide administration
look like what kind of country will it
have what should the world expect
fantastic well that seems like a good
place to end thank you danny thank you
john
thank you thank you i'm zany minton
bedos the economist editor-in-chief
all of our election coverage is up on
economist.com
read it by clicking the link and don't
forget to subscribe
thanks for watching